had what's called forward operating
bases so in a Forward Operating Base of
like those beaufort bows yes forts say
100 recumbent a strength about 100
people normally be there of whom five to
ten maybe maximum would be women and
this is with you know very tough units
like the Argyll and sutherland
highlanders five Scots or two power
units that at the moment are banned from
having women as part of their formal
complement in those environments there
is no spec there are only two showers
you don't have one shower just for the
girls and then have everybody queuing so
you come and go and you can you come and
go with a little towel wrapped around
your backwards and forward to the shower
and when you're working in that
environment and people are being and
these are these are people who are who
are who are who celebrate the fact they
call themselves wretches I mean these
people will do stuff that I can't
possibly tell you in public in
nightclubs just to shock other people
there could you know they're great fun
but they they like to be a bit wrong in
the even in that environment I never
heard a single sexist comment I never
saw any memories really saw any flirting
there clearly were relationship
sometimes further back from the front
line and inevitably then you know people
are sneaking off and doing what grown-up
adults like to do they didn't seem to be
a big problem I mean there was one case
in the six months I was in Camp Bastion
in which a woman fell pregnant or was
pregnant before she deployed and that
was just dealt with as part of the the
normal run of life I mean you can go
nuts over these things or you can
actually just approach it as a mature
adult that's what people did in the
field pregnancy aside how does this
compare to the debate which no longer
exists about gay men being in the Armed
Forces you know the traditional
regressive argument that it would be a
distraction and it be inappropriate and
there would be sexual problems nobody
nobody credible ever makes that point
anymore it's just assumed that even if
there are gay men with straight men in
the armed forces that they will organize
themselves in a way that's respectful
and they'll you know they'll manage
their relationships in a way that
doesn't disrupt their work yeah in the
experience I had and this is probably
something to do with the how far we've
moves as a society
in this sort of uber macho environment
of two para or whatever it is you'd
never hear a homophobic comment because
you wouldn't know who was gay and who
was straight and several of them are
quite happy to exhibit gay behavior just
because they thought it might be funny
or part of the fun and games there was a
very very kind of 21st century approach
frankly it was just just just wasn't a
thing I mean people might call each
other gay as a as a sort of vague in
somewhat but what I mean is that just
being a bit wet but the the it was
extraordinary in that context how far it
had moved if if the objection about
sexual temptation has gone away you know
it's been disproved in reality and
practice and so much of the army is
already integrated with women in it then
I guess you're just left with this I
think regressive idea about gender and
the argument that being in active combat
involves aggression and ferocity and a
killer instinct is always the phrase
that's used which doesn't come natural
either it doesn't come naturally to
women or it's not something that should
be encouraged in women and therefore
it's kind of against nature to allow
women and active combat which to me
seems a incredible argument for anybody
to make with a straight face oh good I
you don't make it I'm not but but but
the bit the reservation I have when I
hear that is that it doesn't feel ideal
to me to encourage anyone in our society
to develop that kind of behavior and
that's why we have so many problems with
people who have been in active combat
trying to reintegrate into normal life I
mean they form a huge disapproval cases
there are overrepresented and domestic
violence and drug abuse there's PTSD I
feel like it's another reminder that we
should kind of ask ourselves what kind
of people we expect our soldiers to
become whether they're male or female
that's problematic the kind of people we
expect our soldiers to become our kind
of merciless killers with a brain that's
what you are you're not this is not
you're not recruiting for paramedics
you're recruiting to somebody who
without the slightest hesitation will
cause somebody else's head to explode at
close range that is the job of a
frontline soldier to run them through
with cold steel at this distance between
you and I now they certainly are women
capable of doing that because I've been
in combat
with them in every patrol I was in in
Afghanistan there are at least one woman
present sometimes in early you think
anyone do you come across anyone who's
seriously making the argument that women
aren't capable of that kind of behavior
all that they shouldn't be encouraged to
exhibit it because they're women rather
than because it's no no no I've never
heard that the only argument you here
against women in the frontline roles in
the military is either the issue about
discipline and sexual tension and that
kind of stuff which i think is nonsense
since it's been proven in combat both in
Iraq and Afghanistan over a very
sustained period of time in which the
presence of women right on the front
line is not inimical to good discipline
so I think that's a nonsense argument
whoever makes it they just haven't been
there I think that does tend to be there
an awful lot of armchair officers if you
like who got off about this stuff and
have no experience of what it really
really means there is I think a
perfectly sound argument about physical
capability but I don't think that that
should be spread out across all winning
okay let's talk about that because there
are biological differences between the
genders there are even though there are
women who are stronger than the average
man and I'm sure there are male soldiers
who aren't in not saying anything Sam
how much did you score this week there
are there are male soldiers who I'm sure
on at the same physical peak that they
would be expected to be all the time
people must we just don't get into the
you don't get you won't be be able to
remain in a frontline unit in a
frontline role unless you meet certain
basic athletic staff those basic
athletic standards are you saying that
women aren't capable of meet their
different at the moment they're
different from men and women so the
combat fitness I can't remember the
exact statistics but you can be combat
fit as a woman but you won't have to
carry the same amount of weight over the
same distance in the same period of time
so this is being used as an argument for
saying they're for women should not be
in frontline combat roles and certainly
and again they won't get through these
objective standards because okay the
fastest man runs faster than the fastest
women but a woman who is within her
relative fitness peak or the highest
level of fitness for women arguably has
as much endurance stamina and strength
as a man who
level of fitness within the range for a
man yeah so so that's fine if you're
doing athletic pursuits but war is not a
sport it's about being overwhelmed or
overwhelming so if you've got half women
and half men in your unit and you're
facing the same number of enormous
Russians you know which would you which
unit would you rather be in you know the
one that is has a relative sense of
capability or the one with an absolute
sense of capability but what are the
actual physical limitations that would
mean women faced with those massive
Russians West if you chose that as an
example by the well no it's very likely
because you can't carry as much weight
you can't carry as many machine-gun
bullets you're not as useful next to me
as my buddy unless you can carry 200
rounds we only can carry 100 rounds that
leaves me a hundred rounds short and I'm
going to get shot by the other guys you
know it is an absolute thing but and
this is where I think that there need
not be this absolute ban on women and I
think that's why the Prime Minister is
sort of getting trying to maneuver the
military excuse the pun into position
where they don't have this absolute
moratorium on women is that if you are
capable of passing the male standards
for those units then you should have
every right to be exploited by those
units as another body to throw at the
enemy that doesn't make any sense to me
to exclude women from combat but at the
end of the day would you as a woman who
would presumably eventually be allowed
to serve in a frontline combat unit be
prepared to put your name down for
conscription but that is the essential
point and you know I was in Bournemouth
last summer where they had they have the
M the air show every summer and there's
an incredibly aggressive propagandist
recruitment drive that goes on at the
same time so I didn't didn't know
anything about before I went there for
the Armed Forces and it's an area with a
very poor white working class population
there are a lot of 16 17 year-olds who
haven't done well at school have very
limited job prospects and you can see
this is aimed directly at them to me
that feels problematic it's like you're
exploiting people who don't have very
many opportunities to become potentially
cannon fodder and an age when they can't
necessarily make the most informed
choices about such serious like
long decisions they can't vote all right
I don't want to be I'm not a
propagandist
you